what a dramatic evening in politics and
for the country of course uh if you
don't know already you're joining us
shortly after the resignation of the
chancellor of the exchequer and the
education secretary rishi sunak and
sajid javid after a statement by the
prime minister joining me now is will
walden who was press secondary to mr
johnson when he was the mayor of london
good to talk to you will uh just give us
your reaction first of all to to the
events and i'll add on as everyone's
asking can the prime minister hang on uh
evening derby i i think the short answer
to that is it's very difficult to see
how now
having lost your chancellor in the
middle of the cost of living crisis in
your health secretary with four tenths
of your mps against you and probably
frankly after the two by elections and
the chris printer affair a fair few more
it's very difficult to see how he hangs
on uh he is a fighter and he's nothing
if not uh resolute and determined and
clearly the message is already going out
that he's going nowhere they'll have to
get rid of him uh but i can't see how
this
becomes tenable and i and i think that
the difficulty for boris is that again
it's a self-inflicted wound um they have
tried because you know boris was loyal
to chris pincher and wanted him around
in february and needed him as uh and
rewarded him for his efforts to keep him
in power he made him deputy chief whip
they almost would have been better on
friday coming out and confronting that
and just saying
what happened in the past happened in
the past the prime minister was
satisfied with this he spoke to the
ethics committee but what they've done
instead is that they whether it be the
prime minister or whether the people
that speak for him they have left a
situation where you know nothing was
happening on friday and then something
was happening over the weekend and oh
yes he did know this and again it's just
like partygate and then he's forced to
come and apologize for a lapse in
judgment and the problem tonight is that
the prime minister is essentially doing
what he's done throughout all of the
last eight months he's blaming others so
for for partygate he was blaming the
media for reporting it and people to for
listening to it and he really at the end
of the day wasn't that sorry about it
tonight he's blaming him
but what about you know what about the
downing street operation i mean there
are parallels here not with the the
allegations but parallels all the way
back it seems that the in the autumn of
last year with owen patterson gate if i
can call it that in that
people were being sent out ministers
were being sent out to say things that
they'd been told by downing street which
subsequently turned out not to be
exactly true and that really upsets
people doesn't it and that's what it
seems has led to this evening so what
about a change what about a change of
the personnel once again how many has he
had so far two or three
well this is the third iteration derma i
don't i don't think that the change of
personnel is going to do it now um we we
have a situation where cabinet ministers
are resigning and presumably others are
thinking about their position tonight
now jacob rees-mogg very loyal you know
he's going to say anything short of
losing a vote the prime minister should
stay i i can't see how changing the team
is going to make any difference to uh
backbenchers or cabinet ministers and
even if the rest of the cabinet doesn't
move against him i suspect what we'll
see is a
change in the leadership and the
constitution of the committee of the
1922 and rather than waiting six months
i suspect they'll move quickly to have a
vote of confidence which at the moment i
suspect the prime minister even deep
down if he's being honest himself knows
he's probably going to lose and that
that is why the writing is on the wall
but but i think that you know he will
take the view that um you know onward
and upward um you know new chancel a new
health secretary on we go i think the
problem is that the the party now
whether it be activists whether it be
members whether it be back bench mps
whether it now be members of cabinet
ministers are walking in a different
direction